sometimes I wonder why these happen to
people like I didn't want to [ __ ] VI
here nobody ever wants to be here but
it's like damn like why does life make
it so hard to want to be different like
why is it that no matter what you do
well your life always just surrounded by
the same thing like me like I've tried
moving away you know like I've taken
means like I don't need to smoke I don't
need to smoke you know I don't need to
do anything not here but it's like I sit
there and I i've tried moving away i've
tried staying sober not smoking I've
tried [ __ ] everything and just say no
matter how hard I try it just seemed to
get sucked back into the sauce I mean
I'm sick and tired of it already like I
don't want to be over do you think it's
something to do with the childhood that
you had that makes you believe you don't
work deserve anything better
then keep see you down here I mean I
know I deserve better it's just that
hunt amused about I don't know how the
means to go about getting skinny oh you
should've seen this one time it's just a
big fat guy right huge marine industry
[ __ ] naked like that's when they get
like running like ha I felt bad after
but I recorded it it was pretty funny so
Christina yes sir so this has been a
month or so since our last talk and a
lot of people including myself found you
very interesting yeah you've come from a
very tough situation your your family
kind of left you high and dry it sounds
like and
you're homeless you're living a very
rough life well I mean what do you think
would help your situation
I mean first starter is like soso you're
16
yeah and you know you're 16 you've got
basically eighth-grade education you
have a criminal record - right yeah not
like not too extensive but yeah yeah and
you're homeless
yeah like honestly like and you have a
daughter
where's your daughter they took her when
I had her so she wears the foster system
nah no I'm sure that's a bad family you
connect kids she where she got adopted
by a family who couldn't have kids
boys I'm currently don't like cuz when I
was not one date we didn't take her when
I called my mom and I told my mom like
hey I need your help you know like for
once in your life like help me out you
know because I feel like they were
ripping my soul away from me that guy
was like damn like no like I didn't know
what to do I freaked out so I just
called my mom like cuz I obviously it
means like being young it's like the
first thing you think about when you're
in trouble or we need your eider when
you're scared when you're like what you
know like wakey now is like like mom
like the one honesty you know I'm mommy
so I called her in a toilet hey can you
pick up my baby they turn to take her
she was just like there's always like a
personal bond you should thought about
the way he ran away and she hung up on
me healthy why did they take your baby
drugs yes hi dragon my system right okay
I was I was already six months pregnant
but I wasn't even showing like I what I
I thought that was pretty because I felt
her move you know and I didn't bother
going to hospital team because my baby's
dad won't let me because he swore that I
was sort of like everybody even though I
wasn't so he wasn't anywhere the
hospital or doctor anything that
attacked you just keep me locked up in
the house right and so by the time I
turned to six months I thought it was
three but in red I was six and so my
plan wasn't right three months before I
think it bril I was just like no make
sure sucky high and it just didn't work
out that way cuz like my baby daddy
didn't let me go hospitals so slowly
yeah I couldn't like I didn't know what
I exactly how far along I was do you
have anyone in your life that you trust
or that even you can go to and in a
tough situation and just this guy told
you about yeah it's good to have
somebody yeah I mean he cared much you
know because he's in the same position
that I'm in but it's like no but
somebody's bounce ideas off of it's
somebody that I can tell anything to and
he'll figure out the best way to help me
like I've never had somebody help me but
mostly I think it's time I get emotional
support yeah
cuz it's never fast apart could we put
broke his book but it's like yeah it
helps me be like him being there like if
I didn't have him right or not I don't
know where I'd be I applaud y'all gave
me or something you know like he taught
me that there's more to life than just
this I think there's more to life than
just Skid Row because at first that's
what I thought I remember one time I
[ __ ] fell asleep in his car right
when I woke up I was the most [ __ ]
gorgeous view I've ever seen in my life
like it was amazing like was badass and
I turned to him and I was like why did
you bring me here he was like you see
that I was like see what he's like look
outside and I look and he's like that's
life he's like that's what life is
it's like because not what you think it
is and ever since then I just kind of
started like slowing down you yeah I
know what you're this life here on Skid
Row is definitely not it goes fast
faster you can be walking she one minute
next minute you know you're getting
you're getting until I was something for
an all [ __ ] reason just for the [ __ ]
of it it kind of sucks
they nodded think about it like I did a
lot of stupid [ __ ] you know I'm doing a
lot of stupid [ __ ] still and it's like I
don't want to go back to my parents or
anything I thought cuz I'm already
independent as it is you know like I've
had to survive this on how you by myself
so like what the [ __ ] don't need that
for but I don't want to be out here
either like hey I honestly like my goal
is you just like get my own spot
start over I just cool and just be cool
you know they're my life
that'd be great a couple of steps school
for sure but like for example like I've
saved up money in a spot like three
times already and every time once it
gets like a good amount so I'm thinking
about it okay like I can finally start
looking for something either got stolen
or like this last time we got burned
cuz my father down or just goes missing
nobody knows Lebon so you so use meth
but you don't seem like an addict are
you addicted to crystal meth yeah yeah
you just look at that what I wrong
yeah you seem you don't seem to be this
hardcore is a lot of people I've given
up I'm like dude calm down it's cuz
there's this phrase that everyone uses
out here it's I do drugs the drug home
to me but there's some people that you
looking at me like nay your burnt the
[ __ ] out look at you drugs no definitely
do I think it's like
if I could just get enough money to get
my own spot and leave far away from here
I'll play never come back
like ever yeah well you seem a lot less
angry today than you did last time I
talked to you here you see him to be
just like last time I was angry bus
machines how you know you're hell-bent
on self-destructing and today you've
seen a little more level-headed which is
nice this is I usually I'm when I get
mad you start thinking that guy that's
crazy [ __ ] before I would have done it
you know like all know what do the
statistics presented and I would've
gotta go do it I got late you know now
I'm just like it's not even worth daily
for what are we gonna get from that so
what you would do is get it get situated
somewhere away from here very far away
from here I did a high school education
yeah I already enrolled already rolled
into a school but they're charging me
and so I sent them a heck a handwritten
letter explaining my situation and I was
still waiting for them to get back with
me see what's up I have you know they're
gonna do it those schools never do those
don't ever do that is that how do you
doubt they're gonna do it though say you
know schools never do that excuse me I'm
hoping they do though thank
because once I can do that once I can
get away from your like at the end of
the day it's like I don't need to be
here like there's nothing here that's
good for me like to where it's helping
me any kind of weight or there would be
emotional religious emotion like
emotional again like most emotion law
I'm like a really emotional person but
it's like ain't nobody giving me money
oh you're a nobody helping me out
ain't nobody [ __ ] giving me love and
affection nobody's looking
there's no reason it's question behavior
I don't even talk to my other anymore so
it's like you know so the gang
connections you had it's kind of gone I
cut off yeah I told them I was like look
I have a baby I was like I'm straight
I'm cool I put him out work hurry like I
already did my job
then I was your cuz he's a guinea pig
for cutting a few years like either you
guys let me leave I'll make you let me
look I was like if I find that you guys
are coming out to me like I will find
you okay I know everything about each
never eat so many guys cuz I don't make
music antsy because I said it can't the
advantage of them like like making me a
person that I am because it's like if
they were taught me other loopholes in
other ways and all the things that they
do then you would never know how to get
that person back you know but since you
know everything about that person or
that group whatever use your advantage
because she know exactly how they gonna
move and because there's so many of them
it's like they can't change it up they
have to move that way and so it gives me
an advantage as I steer clear from them
you know I try to avoid them as much as
possible give it all the the rough stuff
that you see in the tough childhood
you've had what I mean how do you see
life do you see life as it could life is
what you make it
like if you can't accept that you were
wrong and accept hell because there's a
lot of people that are very prideful
thank you stream is very cool like I
used to be really prideful if I would
never go to a shelter or take food from
people I give it out you know because I
felt like not I can be seen any mats
look and then like all of a sudden I
realize like yo
I think it's not even like that like
you're supposed to take the help we were
supposed to want help like you're not
supposed to want to be out here all
hardcore like oh yeah I'm not gonna get
[ __ ] I can do it myself that's not the
way that works like the way that I'm
supposed to be like they're supposed to
strive to do things better
he's supposed to strive to be the best
person you can be and at this point the
only thing I was like I don't want my
daughter to grow up and try to find me
and me be all [ __ ] off in a [ __ ]
you know in the dates or something I
don't want her to like grow up and try
to find me and find out that I'm cause
like my mom made my mama's I just
[ __ ] crack being a prostitute right
there I'm [ __ ] so she call them [ __ ]
no right here right now they didn't
leave on the burner there you go
that she say mom's biggest rate
prostitute on I got that they should she
look at me think she later like this
house worth all day smoking crack and
hopping into cars nothing right I think
each other own designated corner it's
kind of funny
exactly it's like if they play musical
chairs I think like once we'll have 1/2
the new car like the next one goes that
way I think the cost is reading and my
mom will cross this way and then like
that won't cause this way and none of
them fill in the corners Metheny sure
I've seen your mama is what I was you
Michelle oh yeah yeah I got into it with
her with her boyfriend a couple days ago
because he was hitting here I just told
me and I had already brought him like a
few times I was like really you put eyes
on my mom again dog we're gonna have
issues I mean like now I feel like I'm
more mature [ __ ] so I don't like
getting like that people don't work I
don't want to be that person it's better
to be respected and feared you know but
I've come to realize that the fear that
I put in people back then is now
affecting my respect level and I'm
getting from them now because now
they're seeing like oh she's calming
down oh yeah I remember that [ __ ] said
this listen is to me [ __ ] that [ __ ] and
I don't calm down not in restaurant do
anything nobody that's probably seen
advantage of like you know trying to get
back at me like revenge type [ __ ] do you
think seeing the situation that maybe
you're like your mom is in or some of
the other older women helps you most
definitely I've never I've never tried
crack in my life ever ever ever never
ever ever or coke hmm your mom is crap
and you still haven't so much crackin so
much cuz I'm funny but but seeing these
I seen my mom's friends and my mom doing
that me going up I swore I was ever
gonna do it cuz I refuse to end up like
that so you think it might help you
break the cycle you didn't even though
you've lost your daughter but you're
still young and you could have 17 market
I don't look when I when I came out here
my goal was okay I'm gonna find my mom
and I'm gonna tell her I'm afraid and
then we're gonna go live happily ever
after
that was my childish thinking you know
and it was like I was so disappointed
when I found my mom like so disappointed
like like it broke me like because I had
these expectations in my mind but I come
to find out that she's just [ __ ]
another crackhead prostitute on the
street and then it's like damn like I
don't want my butt to my daughter to see
me that way she's already gonna have
some sort of rosette towards me because
of the fact that I died exams on her you
know and say she's not gonna know the
detail she's not gonna really happen
she's not gonna know where else today at
the time that I was young and I was
scared like I'm just hoping that I'm in
a way better position than I am now so
when she does find me if hopefully
she does that I can't explain it to her
can you cuz I know for a fact that she
were to find me about here's 20 minutes
Emma day can you envision the difference
that your daughter one day one day your
daughter will be your age and she'll
talk to you hopefully and the difference
between you being in a situation like
your mom or similar to that or you know
where you are and where your mom is is
kind of like yeah you could be a high
school graduate you could have your life
together you could be far from Skid Row
that's maybe just right now like I know
for a fact she won't you meet somebody
wife is like like when I had her today
it was a trip like she was just like me
like I gave me identical like I swear
like her whole facial structures like
all me
like it is thing little guy have a baby
day it looks like I [ __ ] myself ahead of
maybe like like yeah there's like no
there's no like I said to her face that
this looks like mine like I was trippin
off it's like her attitude to like would
you give much was even crying she was
looking at the nurse like be sure you
touching me if you just give you this
face like she's your personality and so
that's how I know like I know for a fact
if she goes up and finds out here she's
gonna really literally just don't give
me you just walk away because that's
what I would do that's why I didn't
actually I see my mom I told I was like
[ __ ] you I just walked away I just tried
to talk to me in everything I was a
[ __ ] like why are you talking me are
you in front of it I don't want [ __ ] to
do is [ __ ] you what are you doing here
like you couldn't even like like I
wasn't enough for you to want to do
better but that's how he is so I thought
that's how she's here I think and sounds
like you know like I'd rather not I
really think I'd rather just be good
have my own spot or just a you know if
she wants to come over they she I just
you know wishful thinking but I know
that if I get to it and I actually do it
it's it's like you know nine times out
of 10 more likely to happen
there is that slight mean percent but
you know what's your favorite thing
about yourself
my network my network I think that
that's like one of the best thing that I
have I mean I would hear at least your
social skills yeah my knowledge about
things cuz I know I don't know
everything but I know a little bit about
a lot of things like I can't build you a
house but I know how to [ __ ] nail a
nail you know like I can't freakin do
the whole pipeline things those a
compliment but I know how to [ __ ]
like they fix the toilet like no it's a
drain oh [ __ ]
I can't forget paint you some mold like
so [ __ ] like Angelo [ __ ] but I can I
can draw you a pretty picture should I
thought you know I don't want to do
everything in the right way supposed to
be done but I know how to do it my way
my way is still as I do I help out like
a lot okay then that's alright I'm
helpful your kind I think sometimes too
much I allow people to get away with
certain things that I shouldn't allow
that's why I feel like that's why I feel
more and more every day like I'm not
meant to be out here like the way I am
is just not meant to be how you're like
I the people that are oh you're like
their grimy their conniving and they
will [ __ ] get you whatever they get
there's a world outside of here that
isn't way exactly it's like the way I
because I I before I would feel back to
me you should to people like I would
think about it I my conscience would
[ __ ] with me like damn like I just did
that's that person like that was
somebody's mom somebody's brother his
sister cousin son daughter or the [ __ ]
you know like I would think about the
after like the aftermath like [ __ ] like
I wonder like other families doing like
damn like the plague devastated like ya
know we may be just like [ __ ] you know I
was really like like the biggest
motivations for me to tell my hood like
yeah you know we're like cuz it was just
it's too much I'm not meant for that
kind of [ __ ] I was dragging to it on
purpose
they seen something good and they wanted
to destroy it because misery loves
company so they grabbed it and they try
to destroy me but yet I'm still here
well it's very encouraging to hear you
today because today you sound like
hopeful and positive and willing to do
whatever it takes to kind of improve
your situation yeah sure we're hopefully
doing that yeah because that day that it
doesn't hurt him I look at myself in the
mirror just like I thought about like
everything and I thought like I honestly
looked at you and I was like that could
have been me cuz like I wanted to be a
photographer 1.0 and so it's like that
could have been me but I [ __ ] up
you're only 16 you got plenty of time I
know you could be 26 and just still got
plenty of time I feel like give me 36 I
think what I've been through out here if
I ever were to hopefully get a normal
life like I'm normal like just like
stable like stability like for every
test ability like I feel like that would
take a toll on the way people are around
me and the opportunities I might be able
to get because people was a completely
different I mean like people would look
at me like oh that's like a membrane or
oh look at stuff like no or like cuz
I've had people tell me like recently
like oh stop trying to be something
you're not
and I would he talking about cuz me like
before I wouldn't give a [ __ ] I looked I
would look like [ __ ] all done then again
I kind of like [ __ ]
I was tired but um it's like I started
to give a [ __ ] about what people like
how people view me the way I look to
people that's why I don't act like an
addict that's why don't be wigging the
[ __ ] out running our Nick in the street
you know why because it's like like it's
not that I give a [ __ ] about my
reputation is to give a [ __ ] about
myself like like I don't want to look
all dirty and nasty like cuz I mean like
I walked into the store people looking
all weird I hated that feeling I swear
to God I hated that feeling like back
then I would walk hour I will walk into
a store or something right and people
just look at me
you know and that feeling that a gave me
was just like sucked so I was like you
know what like I can't be can't can't be
doing that [ __ ] so I was like I'm just
and people put that me like oh like what
you think that is because you're dressed
in different and and you're looking
clean and [ __ ] that people to know who
you are like who you are I was I don't
give a [ __ ] thing on my own house
they didn't got no one to I was like in
this drawers I can trust we'll never get
some that person how's it good you don't
deserve it like [ __ ] no I think that
attitude is is a key attitude in terms
of getting your life to where you want
to see all these people are you could
suck all this shouldn't they want once
they can't get on my level and they've
been through the [ __ ] that I've been
through and they can actually know what
it feels like to be in my position then
they can come get me other than that
they need you she doesn't [ __ ] up if
they got an issue with me saying that
they can we can get that was good
like at the end of the day it's like
regardless whether I fight that person
or not it's not gonna change anything in
my life
my still gonna go on after that I think
words to effect me a lot though
like I'm really like like I said
emotional person but at the end of the
day like when it comes to people that
are irrelevant it's like they give
somebody that I don't give a [ __ ] about
I think I sit there called me [ __ ] ho
[ __ ] [ __ ] the homeless bum whatever
the [ __ ] ugly [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ]
I don't care it's like you're relevant
shut the [ __ ] up I don't care but
someday I give a [ __ ] about that I mean
I'm gonna take into consideration what
the telling me because obviously that's
something for a reason you know that's
something that this guy taught me the
things bliss like BL is s
everyone's got a street name and yours
is homicide but I think he's a veteran
I think he's way better I just couldn't
use your first video
it is way more approachable I imagine
like you're walking into the room and
you're kids you do see that person I go
hi my name's bliss like a lie then like
you to get to me if they're having any
sounds that ethical I met up as always
I'm a grown as people will be like oh
and like white like like look at me I'm
cute cuddly why everyone's got a street
name down here everyone no one's mic or
Joe or Karen no there is like big white
no there are there's a few there's a few
but it's just so cool to have a street
name I guess and then it's I give you
somebody's government name is they use
their cover my name oh my god how dare
you it's like the biggest insult cuz
only clubs is both know that if you ever
got your self out of Skid Row out of
this world
would you ever miss it no would you ever
come back hail God it's a great hell no
people say oh I want to come back and
hell not even that you know that good
news I love hearing you say that they
know exactly what the [ __ ] they're doing
they know is that clear to get out of a
there's choosing not to because I like
to [ __ ] they like to [ __ ] everybody and
it's honestly out here like this area
here is literally I kid you not one big
ass orgy it's all it is one big ass drug
induced orgy I swear to God like
everyone's [ __ ] everyone no
responsibilities nothing everyone's
having sex with everybody do you see
[ __ ] packs of condoms on the street
there's enough balloons for dialogue
everyone's doing drugs they use it a
face the bikes the cops the cops cruise
by and know that this is all going on
dude honestly I won't play in my life I
was sitting with my mom right and I was
trying to tell her like mama come move
to my spot at least you won't be here
you know cuz I first I thought my mom
didn't like it cuz she made it seem like
if she's being forced to do it
oh there mama go so good that she today
thank you I've come over here with guns
before they meet my friends I'm not my
homies my friends they'll be like you're
wrong tribute I put the [ __ ] didn't you
forgot you and we'll show but guns is
she trying get my mom out of here all
the time
second date like look it's like I had to
like teach myself like okay like she's
choosing viu she likes this lifestyle
leave her alone it's always been there
I'm long sing her crap I couple they see
me I'm like wash cuz I was around that
it's good time I was like [ __ ]
oh they kick it up and run my mall isn't
way inside that there's a gang of people
inside [ __ ] so just ed I just stood up
and I was just like I know I know I
couldn't wrap my head before I got out
of the clouds our gig and then they're
literally sit there like frisking me and
my mom was just in there I was like oh
my god what the [ __ ] did you feel like
your family or the world is like failed
you um yet maybe if I was like
30-something a Sawyer
yeah then a little bit so you don't you
don't have a victim mentality know what
uh hopeful hopefully I get the [ __ ] up
out of here please help me some [ __ ]
isn't your person always very different
today like I'm like my god like I want
to be hearing like I don't I'm miserable
are you like and say I know I'm know I'm
capable of doing a lot of things but
till I get out of here like it's pretty
much useless and then I can feel myself
slowly fading away like myself me the
person I started off alright first
person I hear it's really hard for me to
remember the feeling of who that person
was like its distant like it's fading
and really fast and I don't like to go
away because once it goes away it means
that this place one like it's a it's a
go war each each and every single one of
these wire is that a war with themselves
bliss told me something he told me life
is nothing but a fight against your own
disbelief solution is whatever you don't
believe you can do is what you're
fighting against
like I made sex is like damn like I
before I would never thought it was B I
would never believe it like not with
that you know but yeah look at me it's
like life is really a fight guys show
disbelief so if you believe you can do
something then you're not gonna do it so
that's why I tried I'm trying to keep my
head straight think that okay I can do
this I can do this I can do this there's
just hardly I can't get resources or
anything because it's like I'm 16
yeah he's like I can't go to go to my
mom and dad sounds like hey possibly no
but like after listening to your first
the first time you came by a month ago
you seemed so self-destructive and just
hell-bent on you know hating everything
and that made it difficult for me to get
behind helping you but the Kristina that
came by today this who you are right now
is very easy for me to feel like helping
you it might be a good thing to do it's
like I didn't realize like done like you
know you know like I am to be right now
like a lot of people a lot of people
thinking oh nice just like you know it's
money it's not just money like people
are gonna watch this people are gonna
see you like like make it worth it don't
just [ __ ] throw it away for some for
some quick cash
it's like it's not worth it like make a
difference like you know like make your
little mark in the universe somehow like
years from now somebody might be like
hey I won't go it's like YouTube like
you know or like who knows they could
show this video to some girl who just
ran away cuz I remember my group home
they thought it showed me videos like on
YouTube about people in their stories
and at first I didn't want to listen to
it but now I understand why like what if
she watches this and she thinks like
[ __ ] I don't want to be like that and
she stays then she'd go to graduate
college and become something you know
she's gonna feedback me like [ __ ] if I
want to see that video that girl I would
never made it here you know like I think
about you like that like
I think about I I think about the good
things in life most of its but I'd
rather see the cup as half full not half
empty cuz I used to see the couples have
everything I was like a whole person I
was just like a [ __ ] everything of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] it all looking destructive and
that's what you were about to go when
you're here cuz I was giving up her do
you think I was like slowly just like
giving up but I'll just say [ __ ] him
done with everything like I didn't see
myself getting out of here anytime soon
they just stole my money again so I was
like you know what like [ __ ] it I guess
this is what it is no but now would you
telling me this it's like okay that's
pretty yeah well see what you can do
don't try to help you out great can't
promise anything but we'll see I hope
all right doing these guys basic all
that you're so cute cuddly
I got teddy bear you oh yeah
you